what is the coolest thing about Pluto
its temperature that was easy
for me it's that it's a planet out there
far from the Sun small but has moons of
its own and also the fact that my
daughter did her fourth grade project on
Pluto Pluto has glaciers that appear to
be flowing there may even be ice
volcanoes on it and Pluto is a tiny
little body it really should have lost
all of its heat a long time ago it's
nowhere near the Sun and it's nowhere
near another massive planet that could
keep it warm with the gravity so we are
really lost we don't understand how Pido
can be so active so in fact the coolest
thing about Pluto is why it's warm
all right next let's say whoo next
question why does Pluto intrigue us so
much maybe because it's the farthest
body up there that used to be a planet
but not anymore
sorry flute oh but also it's it's kind
of the underdog of the solar system
isn't it it's had this interesting
history where we don't know that much
about it and everybody loves a mystery
before New Horizons I mean we had you
know five pixels across of a Hubble
image of Pluto we could see very little
of its surface we didn't know what was
there Pluto is the newest planet we just
saw it up close for the first time that
hasn't happened in a long time we
haven't been this excited since the days
of Voyager finally we had a concerted
effort to send a probe there and it took
you know a decade to get there and then
when we see it it completely blew our
expectations that's a whole world there
with mountain ranges with frozen seas
just covered in ices rock things that we
had never even expected no one expected
Pluto to look like that you know
everyone had their their guesses but of
course nature is always more interesting
than our imaginations
you